you go down going down
[Music]
you want fans to know at home
how did it feel out there oh my God it
was amazing like the fans the music the
lights I mean we're at home and it's the
message I was gonna say the magnitude of
that moment was not lost on us watching
backstage what do you want fans to know
what do you want those at home to know
after that performance just like all
these amazing country music artists we
drag queens are also artists and we
deserve a space to be ourselves express
ourselves and create something wonderful
for everyone to enjoy and we're so
grateful for Kelsey for giving us that
opportunity to perform with her she's
amazing after the performance I saw her
backstage and I acknowledged the iconic
moment between you all and I and I asked
you the same question what do you want
those at home to know about that message
and she says I love
self-expression I love performance and I
love inclusivity what did it mean to get
a call
that you would be a part of this
performance with Kelsey oh my God I mean
it meant so much because any opportunity
for us to share our gift with with the
world is a blessing so it is more of us
having a message to bless other people
it's not it's not bad it's all good it's
all love it's all total Liberation and
it's and that's what the Arts is all
about
uh I just want to say as a drag queen of
color it really meant a lot to me
getting this call because sometimes you
don't get those opportunities it feels
like sometimes that kind of the world
and the industry can be against you and
Kelsey made it really clear in the
rehearsal room and
um even during right before this stage
that she was like take up that space you
know this is your time as well
um and amplify the fact that you're here
um and I I'm really thankful and
appreciative of that fans are going hard
for y'all right now especially down in
Nashville because it's been very tough
and I also wanted to ask you how are you
all doing with your mental health
because this is not easy to see what's
happening
yeah but you know what
um too much is giving much is required
and we have a strong uh um a real job of
being leaders so with that leadership
comes strength so we have to be strong
because people look up to us and we
appreciate that and I take the job on
wholeheartedly because this what we're
here to do we're here to uplift we're
here to set free we're here to lead
people to to a brighter light in this
business
feels so amazing
um I feel like even the song you know if
you're going down I'm going down too it
is about celebration of being a
community and I think that's what we did
on the stage tonight and I really hope
that that transcended to people as well
and it felt like it did
and if there's one thing do not mess
with the lgbtq plus Community okay we're
here we're queer get used to it baby
look great tonight oh my goodness how
about we take off these shoes first I'm
with them I'm let's go let's go
okay feed heard and everything but we
will love a cocktail and a nice steak
okay and that's a wrap on me I'm going
with you for the night
foreign